the year 2021 the problem rent is
expensive in St Paul Minnesota the
solution limit residential rent
increases to 3% a year even if there's a
change in
occupancy sounds like a great idea with
the best of intentions what could
possibly go wrong the initiative did not
account for inflation which you know is
kind of a thing and unlike most rank
control initiatives the new law also
applies to new apartment buildings
discouraging housing construction and
investment which is why multif family
building permits are down over 80% in St
Paul while ramping up in the rest of the
state which explains why St Paul is the
patron saint of tent makers